LARRY ARNN: Watch a
horse go backwards.
It's not very good at that.
If you can see
that about a horse,
you can see it about a person.
[GENTLE MUSIC PLAYS]
For a provisional
explanation, we'll
use the term "good" to mean "a
thing being fully what it is."
That's a good glass.
I don't think it's a great one.
It's not to my taste, anyway.
But it's fine.
It functions.
If you drilled a hole
in the bottom of it,
wouldn't be a good
glass anymore.
I was blessed with a
really great teacher.
And one of the best things he
understood and could explain--
he knew his Aristotle--
was how does it come
to be that we use common nouns?
How can we do that?
Let's see, here-- no.
Everything's too uniform
around here, right?
So pen, pen, right?
They're different.
How do you know?
And yet, you know.
You can say to somebody
in another room, where
neither of you can see what
you're instructing the person
to do, would you please go
and get me a pen on my desk?
And they got no
idea what the thing
is going to look like
when they get there.
But they always find it.
This is light work
for human beings.
This is automatic.
And nobody ever
teaches us to do it.
When we're about two years old,
we all start talking, right?
And no other being ever does.
We have four children.
We didn't teach them to talk.
They just started talking.
In our family, the
children are raised just
like the dogs for
the first two years.
Live on the floor, eat the
food on the floor, you know.
But then they start talking.
Somehow they can do that.
And the dogs never do, right?
They're still stupid.
That's their charm, by the way.
[CHUCKLES]
So Aristotle says
that's how we see good.
Things are defined
by their purpose.
And the point is,
this does this.
And this is a fine point, right?
STUDENT: Yeah.
LARRY ARNN: Yeah.
You're a very precise young man.
And so the point
is, it does this.
And this-- that's
yours-- this does this.
And this does the same
thing, except it's hot.
And it's got a little cool
magnetic top on the top.
So that's their purpose.
They're good at it.
They become hard to recognize
if they're harmed in a way that
defeats the purpose.
The good and the being,
Aristotle writes,
are convertible terms, where
you can use one in a sentence,
you can use the other one.
Good cup, being of the cup.
Good book, being
of the book, right?
Good glasses, being
of the glasses.
The basis of all human
speech is the common noun.
And every time we
identify one, we
are identifying the good
and the being of a thing.
Horses love to run.
And they're beautiful
when they run.
And so their ability to do that,
that's what's awesome, right?
If you think that the word
"education" means lead forth,
watch a horse go forward.
And then watch it go backwards.
It's not very good at that.
Well, the point is, if you
can see that about a horse,
you can see it about
a person, you see.
And then Aristotle
is going to say--
before we're done--
that if you practice up
through these immediate
and sometimes small
virtues every day in a way
to build your character,
those people become good.
Human beings, we're going
to discover, face obstacles.
And the virtues are the good
confrontation and tackling
of those obstacles.
And if you do that, it will
change you and make you better.
You can become awesome.
Start today.
[CLASSIC MUSIC PLAYS]
I am Larry Arnn, president
of Hillsdale College.
You will find, if you look
at our online courses,
that they cover the whole
range of human learning,
all the high and fundamental
things everyone needs to know.
They are free,
because we have always
wished to provide sound
learning to anyone
who wishes to have it.